what up this your boy Al Harrington and
check me out on the bootleg cab podcast
talking everything Viola hoop check us
out
bootle cap show special guest in here
NBA legend grew up watching this guy Al
Harrington is here what's up baby hey
man good to see you bro thanks for
having me dogs uh the Cannabis uh I
would like to I was just telling you off
off camera but you're like one of the OG
guys who really got into the weed game
and like did it the right way you just
celebrated 10 years uh two years almost
two years ago now that's crazy yeah bro
so I mean
we've seen a lot of celebrities come and
go in the weed space right like I was
just thinking about this the other day
like me and my boy were talking about
like Jay-Z's weed we're like what
happened to that right what happened to
Jay-Z's weed like it was a
what was it right you know what I mean
but like I feel like you've done such a
great job of just like diving in
obviously being a smoker
um coming from the background you come
from like for you like
how does it feel to kind of
look back you have a has your weed
career almost matched your MBA career
your voice bro almost I'm at I'm at 12
in the week game and I play 16. wow so
uh I'm getting close but I think the
first thing is like I never considered
my brand a celebrity brand right you
know what I'm saying no that's what's
crazy is you kind of had to do a little
diving in to be like oh Al Harrington's
behind yeah it was never LED that was
never the intention right right the
attention was always about my
grandmother and really about just you
know the benefits and changing the
stigma around kids be only your
grandma's name was my grandma okay okay
so that makes sense okay yeah yeah yeah
so the story goes pretty much I had uh
she had come to see me play uh she was
you know taking all this medication back
so why she gave me a list of things one
of the things she said was glaucoma I
told her about the article I was reading
literally two days before she got there
about how cannabis cure glaucoma
patients she asked me what was Cannabis
I said marijuana week she's laughed so
hard she was like rifa you trying to get
me to smoke
and I was like well Grandma they said
doctors she's like no the next day she
comes I come home from shoot around and
she's complaining saying how she can't
see so I said look just try this to be
our secret I won't tell nobody this will
be me and you just you and me you don't
say I have my boy go to dispensary
bought some Vietnam cushions of string
that we bought back
um had her try it so I took her
downstairs where were you playing at at
the time I was playing in Denver okay so
yeah that's getting going you know what
I'm saying so took it downstairs I went
took my nap hour and a half later I had
smoked weed at one time in my life and
it was in Phoenix okay and I was so
paranoid that night I was like I'll
Never Smoke Weed again dead ass so like
[__] we I don't know why y'all smoked
this [__] type thing so I said make sure
she's not going down and you know going
she's not dealing with the same thing so
I go downstairs knock on the door I
don't hear nothing so I'm like well she
must be knocked out so I knock again and
I just open the door but when I open the
door she's sitting at the edge of the
bed and her back to the door she's
looking down so I said Grandma how you
feeling and she literally she turns
around and she's crying too she says I'm
Healed she said you know I haven't been
able to read the words in my Bible in
over three and a half years wow so I was
like what she was like every everything
is so bright like God gave me my sight
back so that's what inspired me to learn
about cannabis amazing and pretty much
you know eight months later I made my
first investment I bought a building in
Colorado and I started growing as a
caregiver so all the patients that I had
either had like HIV or cancer and
whatever was left over that we didn't
give to them we sold to dispensaries wow
and that's how I got started you know
what I'm saying so it's always been
about it's amazing but it's always been
about her it's always been about the
power of the plant for me you know what
I'm saying not you know I still to this
day haven't put anything with my image
on it my name on it for sure for sure
yeah it's all been about the plan you
know yeah it's it's crazy I did so what
are the benefits of like someone has HIV
of cannabis because it helps with like
pain okay appetite you know what I'm
saying because they deal with a lot of
efforts yeah for sure absolutely
advertise one of the biggest things you
know what I'm saying yo it's crazy tell
me okay so you get high in Phoenix
because that's where I'm from you guys
played the Suns that night so this is
the reason this is the reason why I got
high bro so I'm playing for Golden State
okay so the year before we had just we
were the We Believe team yeah we had
knocked off Dallas right so the next
year we come back better we think we
really think we're gonna win a
championship that year right so things
that happen during our throughout That
season like we had an opportunity to
trade for Kevin Garnett right and they
did not [__] make who were they gonna
trade for Katie the kid uh Brandon
[__] the kid that we drafted from
North Carolina they wanted like a draft
pick they wouldn't like young players
right right so it was always going to
trade all these players for him they
reneg on the trade we end up wait the
Warriors said no the Warriors said no
bro Jesus so we end up bringing in Chris
Webber okay so Chris Webber comes in but
you know at this point Chris is a shell
of himself a big shout out to the OG
injury the injuries really cooked him at
the end bro he ends up playing like 12
games for us right and out of those 12
games we end up winning like four out of
four out of the 12 games so come down to
the end of the season we need to win all
the games to make the playoffs right so
we last game of the season
um we all we had to do was beat Phoenix
we knew he was going to be Phoenix
because we had Monte Ellis who used to
he asked about 40 but he averaged 40 on
Steve Nash it was literally like give
him the ball and let him busty Nash yeah
Steve was not the greatest defense like
literally that's how we beat them yeah
every game that year just gave Montana
so we knew we were going to win you know
what I'm saying but we needed the
Clippers to beat Denver oh so you you
even if you won you didn't control your
destiny right we just need but we
there's the night before though we still
we so the night before the game we need
Denver excuse me we need the Clippers to
beat Denver and this isn't good Clippers
this is not good Clippers yeah so
obviously they loose so now our season's
over even if we win the game it doesn't
matter right so everybody's frustrated
you know we think we're gonna build off
of last year and you know bearing we you
know we got a good team you know what
I'm saying and everybody they just start
smoking so they like so I'm sitting in
and I'm having a drink they like bro you
got a smoke dog yeah like come on the
season over bro it's over like smoke
yeah so I smoke or whatever and uh like
I said like 30 45 minutes later bro I'm
like okay and I'm like I'm gonna go to
my room yeah
and I went in the room bro I was felt
like the road was closing in on me I
felt like I was hearing Sirens I was
just bugging you know what I'm saying I
can't even go out that night like we go
we know we go out there yeah I even go
out I was like I'm done I just so that
was my first experience smoking weed you
know what I'm saying so I was like I'm
cool and obviously you know that was
weed from the bay so you know it was
something some real real it was some you
know I'm saying not for somebody's first
time first you know what I'm saying so
it just melted your face off and turned
you off I was finished so are you do you
smoke now I smoke every day oh good I'm
high right now shout out to you hell
yeah bro
um it's kind of crazy too because like
did you see this recent clip of Patrick
Beverly saying less than half of the
league
doesn't or no more than half a league
doesn't enjoy playing basketball they're
just in it for the
money essentially right do you like I
feel like like your era it wasn't that
way
I don't know like and also do you like
did you see did you see the clip I saw
it I saw it what do you think about that
I think he I mean when you look kind of
look at what's going on you kind of
believe it right for sure I say that is
just because the fact that they take all
these rest days just like you know like
to your point I era bro like every game
meant something right every [__] game
is something right you understand what
I'm saying like our mindsets was like
every game determined playoff seating
all kind of stuff right what kind of
contract you might get like now guys get
paid when they hurt they get guys that
play you know 30 40 of the games over
three years spending and Superman still
get the super max you know what I'm
saying like shout out to Zion Eden bro
yeah big shout out to him and listen
he's a great place when he's playing
he's like the most he might I think
offensive he's the most efficient player
in the NBA when he's healthy I think two
years ago he was the most efficient
woman China shot broke hand Garden oh
it's crazy got guys like guys literally
won't play anything he said people will
have like literally you've been in the
league for four years and you played 30
or 40 percent of your games and they
matched you out like so now to that
point is like how do you love the game
you know what I'm saying like you like
you off your rookie contract you just
made 200 million dollars like what do I
care about the rest of my career you
know what I'm saying it takes special
players that are thinking about Legacy
and thinking about chasing records you
understand what I'm saying that I think
that will show through and those will be
the guys that will like enjoy throughout
the rest of their careers especially as
being like true hoop fans you know what
I'm saying but I definitely agree with
them man I think that these guys are
more enamored with the lifestyle over
the game right like I said like back
I'll just give you one more example like
when I was coming up like you can't get
hurt bro because you had like a guy
behind you that was like ready they just
needed that opportunity so like if I
rolled my ankle but I got like Jonathan
Bender who hasn't played in 10 games but
he killing in practice every day he's
just waiting I gotta play on a bum ankle
bro you know what I'm saying but
remember Jonathan yeah like so it's just
chained now it's like you go out you sit
for two months you come right back your
spot right there no matter what the
person was doing in front of you they're
trained him first over you know what I'm
saying so I I have to agree with him bro
I think he might be right about that
yeah and I think too because like I have
two kids that both like play they love
basketball you know but there's so much
there there's something to be said about
like the AAU [__] and then also like
Tick Tock and Instagram making a lot of
these like 16 17 year old kids
Super Famous and Rich and Rich before
they even get to the NBA so they're like
when I watch the draft sometimes and I
see like
dudes I see as [__] like
grabbing their hat I'm like bro like
what's up with all this jewelry like
shout out to scoot Henderson who I heard
is absolute Hooper I heard he's gonna be
amazing I heard he's got a generational
talent I heard he's amazing like and I
heard he's got the right mind state but
he was so iced down old family I was
just like
like probably been making money for two
years because he was he went to the gym
overtime thing but you know once he did
that he knew he was never going to
college so now he could do all kind of
deals he had Puma ads before he even got
your you understand what I'm saying like
so to your point because of this name
image and likeness thing which really
means now it's legal that's what it
really should stand for you know what
I'm saying these kids are getting access
to money and I mean even like the kid
Mikey Williams right for sure what I've
heard he's not even an NBA Talent that's
what I heard I never seen him play and
you know whatever I think I met him at
ethica when he was like 15. bro he's
made already made like 15 million
dollars
[Music]
and you know shout out to him I know
he's dealing with whatever he's dealing
with but you see something like that and
you're like
the internet is the component that might
have [__] this kid's career up yeah
that like too much Fame too early too
much Fame too early and that's what you
know and obviously that's what all of
this [__] is that's what media does
right it builds you up to tear you down
you know what I'm saying so
um even that perspective of just like
you know Tick Tock Instagram like it's
making kids famous that aren't even that
good it's just it's that's what you know
what I really enjoyed was I just watched
uh all the smokes podcast this morning I
threw on they had a episode of Austin
Reeves drop and to see like his
perspective he purposely didn't want to
get drafted
he said that the Detroit Pistons wanted
to draft him at 42. right but him and
his team had a tier of teams that he
could fit in right and he said well once
we fall past this number in the second
round it's going to be a two-way
contract no matter what right so when
they wanted to draft him his agent
called him and said we're okay we have a
plan we want to go undrafted so he
decided he bet on himself right because
he knew the Lakers had interest and he
said there was two teams that they had
as the one tier that he could fit in and
like really Thrive and it was the Bucks
and the Lakers so he really liked bet on
himself and like but that's smart I mean
second round picks a lot of times and
it's too I don't fully understand the
two-way contract thing because I wasn't
in when that was right right but when I
was in a second round pick you only got
one it would never really none of these
were guaranteed but it's really like
there's no guarantee it was really like
two years my era it was really like a
two-year guarantee but you think about
it if you got a two-year guarantee I was
a first round pick I had four years
guarantee so it took me two more years
before I could get to some money right
so if you're good in your first the
first year or two you were beat out the
guy that was the first round pick you
know what I'm saying because you'll get
you'll get to a contract faster if you
bet on yourself to your point sometimes
like when you see certain guys because I
look I looked at like uh because I've
been watching a lot of your older
interviews and stuff and
um obviously watched you play I always
thought you were like I would say like
you were like one of those guys who like
would play the Suns or play like a like
a team and you just like be on Sports
and be like yo [__] now Harrington
like 42 tonight like you were you you
had like [__] you were a bucket
getter bro and uh
the pay structure now oh my God you see
like I think of a guy like Jeremy Grant
and the deal he just got and Jeremy
Grant's a good NBA player but you know
he's not an All-Star you know but I
think of Jeremy Grant I'm like I think
he signed for a buck 80. maybe a buck 60
something like that God bless him God
bless him shout out to you get that
money but I'm like yo you're the kind of
guy who in 2023 could have got like a
buck 80. oh my God hands down bro like
to your point like guys this averaging
12 13 points what's happened it's insane
they got to spend the money is the TV or
all the TV all the media stuff is like
taking off crazy uh you see like I think
uh Tatum will be the first guy that's
gonna get I think oh my God Jalen Brown
it's brown he about to get 70 million a
year it's Jalen Brown yeah I think he's
70 million a year that's crazy you know
what I'm saying so even like when Dame
signed that deal and they were like I
was like wait the fifth year 60 what the
[__]
so now like to your point like now just
being like the 10th best player on your
team bro you and you guaranteed 10 to 15
million dollars you know what I'm saying
so the game has changed a lot now I
gotta I gotta pour everything I got into
my son so I got two little boys 75. like
hey guys I hope we get some of that
money
if one of you two make it we're chilling
we're chilling we're doing upset man
um it's crazy too because like what I
appreciated about you is like you really
love to play in the game and when I look
at like your career obviously you had a
very successful NBA career but at a
certain point in time you even like went
and played in China right right so that
was at the end so yeah so but I'm saying
like you don't go and play in China at
the end unless you just love to hoop
yeah I love the game that's like to your
point like
as I was coming up that's all I could
think about was basketball you know what
I'm saying like if somebody told me to
shut up and job I might have listened at
that point I understand what I'm saying
like I mean that's how much I love the
game everything that I did was around
trying to get better trying to feel
better so that's why I like you know a
lot of my teammates and a lot of my
older friends like any time there's like
any type of new technology of a surgery
or a diet they always hit me up because
they know I've tried like everything
yeah just to get another year I've
always I just wanted to play better I
just wanted to be better I want to feel
better I want to you know I just want to
be the best that I could be at all times
and you know when I got towards the end
you know I had a botched knee surgery
and I had got a staph infection from the
surgery didn't know I had it ended up
getting my bloodstream you know could
have died from it you know I had to stay
in the hospital pick line the whole [__]
and you know it anyway all the
articulating cartilage in my needs so
what that is is pretty much like what it
protects the bone and you know I'm bone
on bone so I actually need a knee
replacement
um I've been able to avoid a knee
replacement because of cannabis
so you know I've been able to have an
unbelievable quality of life retire but
when the China opportunity came it was
because of stuff on Marbury who was who
was like a god there yeah people don't
understand like a lot of people by the
way go watch this documentary I bought
it Stefan Mulberry is one of my favorite
NBA players ever when I was a kid
when the sun's traded for him I was very
excited
um but yeah in China he was I think they
have a statue he got a statue of him in
Beijing of all places yeah you know what
I'm saying and you know he called me and
he was like are you done and I was like
no I'm not done man I'm waiting on a
couple teams you know Houston maybe you
know James Harden was trying to get me
to Houston and different things like but
he had Mike danfone as his coach so that
wasn't going to happen but uh so shots
fired for sure but uh he um he called me
and he was like yo I got a couple teams
over here you know what I'm saying so he
gave me a list of teams and I was asking
what is it he was like the one I picked
was fujin the fujin uh surgeons and uh
the reason why I went there was because
of the weather and it was close to Hong
Kong so he was just like whenever you
get a day off you just fly to Hong Kong
and eat regular food and then come back
type thing and uh I ended up being at 56
days bro I couldn't make shout out to
Future great mix
56 nights literally 56 days bro 56 days
it was the day when I was flying in I
knew I wasn't make it I'll just look or
you could just tell yeah I'm sure you're
like this ain't I can't do this it's
just like at the you know at the end of
the day like I say all money ain't good
money listen early in my radio career my
first full-time job I did afternoons at
a station in Boise Idaho oh [__] and as
soon as I got there I said well I'm not
gonna be here longer than a year so I
this [__] is cool but I think for me you
know what I'm saying yeah I told the
general manager which was this lady
named Ricky who knew nothing about
basketball so I was like we're not going
to win no game because the other thing
about China which is cool so you know I
had like a three million dollar contract
was only for three and a half months
right so it's really no time but you
also you get paid a bonus every time you
win and like my bonus was five thousand
dollars cash every win that Ricky
literally comes after the game and gives
me cash and after like the first couple
preseason games I was like bro I'm not
gonna make any extra money we suck who
are these guys on this team like how did
you put this team together you know what
I'm saying so I went to her like maybe
after the third game of the season and I
was like Ricky I'm gonna give you till
Thanksgiving
you got to find my replacement you know
what I'm saying so I got a body I laid
it home on Thanksgiving Day I kissed the
ground when I got home no [__] and
uh you know that was my chain experience
shout out to Dwight man Dwight's out
there shooting threes I got some other
[__] going on I saw another today yeah
you got I mean listen man allegedly
because all right I'm like you're not
listening you never know with the
internet what's doctored and right you
know so I I don't want to put that on
them like why are they doing that to my
man yeah I don't want to put that on
Dwight because I don't know if that's a
thing because again it's the internet I
saw the screenshots yeah it looks crazy
it does look really crazy and also if
that's what he's into whatever right God
bless you shout out to Dwight uh I was
gonna ask you uh what was well first of
all I am a die-hard Suns fan I have well
LeBron's my goat but I have a over mic
yes okay so see I have like a I have
son's toys I got you I gotta yeah okay
why did you play for Mike dantoni ever
was it in New York yeah New York okay
why am I Dan phony
what was your experience with Mike
because I have heard very mixed things
mostly very negative things about Mike
yeah I mean I I don't go into hella
detail but you know it just you know I
just respect coaches that just tell you
the truth all the time you know what I'm
saying don't talk [__] behind my back
don't tell me one thing and then tell
somebody else enough you know what I'm
saying so that's the phony part of it
um the other thing was like
I may be wrong and like I said you know
the one thing I say about athletes you
know we don't have a real concept of
reality right you know what I'm saying
that's what makes us special that's the
reason why this 30 million or 300
million people that play basketball and
aspire to be Pros like 300 and it's only
450. you don't know exactly you know
that's the reason for that I just felt
like we could have been a better team if
we like attempted to play defense like
we literally never did anything for
defense like nothing never practice a
rotation like nothing so I'm just like
how do you expect us to win if we can't
defend you understand what I'm saying
and we used to tell them that and you
know one time you know Larry Hughes fell
out of the the rotation because me and
Larry went to him before practice one
day I was like yo coach listen we
understand like defense isn't a priority
but you know we talked to all the
players and we're all willing to come in
30 minutes before practice like
and he like got all emotional and upset
and offensive and like you think his
defense just like talk you think it's
defense Stephen is the problem we're
like yes we can't defend nobody we don't
know rotations we don't communicate yes
and he got all pissed off and you know
that that just really frustrated me and
it just made me not like him as much as
a coach now obviously I got numbers
under him you know what I'm saying which
is his stylist seven seconds or less
seven seconds it's wide open it's about
getting as many shots as fast as you can
which can be considered bad basketball
you know depending on who you are the
sun's never won a ring and he's never
won a ring and that's and then it makes
for great regular season records and
then you just keep getting jobs yeah you
understand what I'm saying like the the
league and that's what we could cover
that another time too it's just like
they keep recycling the same coaches and
what you think you'll get a different
result why yeah you know what I'm saying
so that's a whole nother thing don't get
me started
so what years were you with the Knicks
uh I think I was the 2016
10 and 11. I got traded this so I got
traded there I think in 2010 was that
like amari's first year
no Amari came right after me okay so
should you were you on the team with
Amari
I left there went to Denver with Melo
and then mellow got traded halfway
through the season and then you ended up
playing with like Landry fields and like
no I played who was all who was all the
random Knicks uh so I played my error
was when I was there it was like okay
Thomas had came back for a second Tracy
McGrady played with us for a second
McGrady played on the nuggets the Knicks
on the night oh nuggets is uh it was
Nene okay Nene was a very underrated guy
um it was
mellow
uh Kenya Martin yeah but when Melo got
traded you played the year after with
that with those guys right with those
guys yeah yeah so that was J.R Smith Jr
uh what's my damn what's my uh uh Ty
Lawson Aaron to follow what was the
light-skinned dude that the Knicks
traded to the um Nick or that they they
traded into the Nuggets but he was like
kind of like borderline like you could
again this guy could be an All-Star
Aaron to follow no Aaron will fall
played for UCLA I'm talking about there
was like a forward was it a small
forward
he was a part of that Nick's mellow
trade oh uh Gallinari no
[__] that's who came Wilson Chandler
Wilson Channel okay that's what I'm
thinking now oh okay I said the name
yeah that's my dog yeah shout out to
Wilson Champion League shout out to
Wilson bro what would you consider your
because you've been a part of some dope
teams obviously shout out to the Pacers
I feel like the Pacers were like
one of those teams that when I think of
the best teams that never got a ring I
think of the Pacers I think I think of
the Suns
um you know I think of
it's a couple versions of the Suns uh
[__] my life
um and then I just you know but but the
Pacers I feel like legit were like
talently
if you look at the roster like one
through eight or nine like the best team
in the league a couple of years in a row
yeah man when I first came in the league
so you know when I first came to the
league it was the year after you know
Mike did the push off to uh Reggie and
hit the shot you know they win that
Series so you know they were so mad they
were licking their wounds they thought
that you know we were winning the next
year no [__] so it was a lockout
year when I came in so they were so
focused that they had training camp the
training camp started when training camp
was supposed to start because Reggie was
like so whenever the seasons do start
we'll be in better shape than anybody so
we literally they had us all there
everybody was there except for I think
Jalen Rose and Dale Davis but everybody
to a man was there was Rick Smith on
that team Rick Smith was on the team too
yeah so bro we did doing all he was in
and out of the practice during that time
because he had bad food so we worked our
ass off up until like maybe Thanksgiving
and then like we'll look like [__] ain't
about to happen and remember they didn't
start until like January or the next
year or whatever but
at that time the league was all about
vets so it was like who had the best
vets at that time you know what I'm
saying and we just ran into the Knicks
and uh Larry Johnson had that four-point
play that four-point play was crazy you
know what I'm saying and that pretty
much knocks us out the box ticks I'm on
minimum way but then the next year man
we get to the finals you know what I'm
saying we get to the finals but we ran
into a [__]
unbelievable Kobe being Bryant and
[__] Shaq that you can't do nothing
with you know what I'm saying and even
we I'ma tell you the funny thing about
that [__] we thought we had a a series
altering moment when Jay Rose Jalen Rose
stepped under Kobe and made him roll his
ankle
we like it you guys were kind of excited
like hey
hey old school basketball yeah you're
like this is that's right go sit your
[__] ass down yes all that like that
was yeah like everybody in the locker
room like yes we got this [__]
out type [__]
and [__] Kobe plays the next game
taped his [__] up kept it moving and not
only kept the movie had like 36 or
something
were you would you like did was that an
on-purpose thing you'll see guys always
try to slide under the landings well
j-roll said I mean I think he's said it
himself he did it on purpose yeah yeah
like you know you know you don't know
that you're going to make him roll his
ankle but you hope something happened
yeah you know what I'm saying and uh
like I said during that time it was no
hoes bars it was just like survival of
the fittest you know what I'm saying so
yeah I would say that it was done on
purpose
I'm assuming throughout that series you
had to have like eventually kind of
ended up on Shaq by accident maybe there
was no no
okay I I was I was uh about to have back
surgery did you ever did you ever like I
got a shack though what was it like
guarding [__] because because they
always say he's the most dominant player
of all time and when and Peak Shack I
just I just you know I don't know what
you can do really bro you pray
um
so when he was in Phoenix
um the big Cactus bro he was he was
rolling down the lane
and I rotated over to take a charge and
when I got there he's having had already
made the commitment and I just closed my
eyes and I said God please
and he hit me and fell on top of me but
you know it just didn't hurt I was like
surprised like boom and I opened my eyes
and he looking right at me he was like
you look at you from Jersey other than
that I would have killed you
he's like looking dead on Tommy like you
look at you from Jersey I was like thank
you big fella
but Garden Shaq was it was impossible
bro but you know when you when I'm
guarding him we gotta double team him so
it's just like I'm just holding them
holding them up as much as I can and
this was my Golden State days yeah you
know what I'm saying we played small
ball so that mean now he got to guard me
on that yeah you're like the big guy on
the team you know what I'm saying so uh
but we had success like I said we beat
him every time you know what I'm saying
but uh Shaq uh
Shaq was a low bro gotta stop the
interview to say about our good Folks at
Odd Socks baby yeah shout out to odd
talks now this is what I love about odd
Sox one their family we love them but
also they have the most comfortable
socks in the [__] world all right now
look they got the craziest licenses you
see the Jolly Rancher these are actually
flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at oddstocks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview
what about just like on the perimeter
hardest guy you've ever had to defend
where you were just like give me the
hardest guy and then the most underrated
Guy where you were like [__] this I
don't think people understand how good
this guy is so my top three I guarded
everybody I guarded Kobe I guarded Braun
um you know I guarded Mike the old mic
you know
Mike yeah that Mike I guarded that mic
um no that's not that Mike is it yeah
that's so that's his last All-Star Game
is it oh okay all right yeah so that
might
um so obviously all tough to guard right
but the guys that like I was just like
[__]
Grant Hill oh yeah before the ankle
mm-hmm so it was like my first two I was
like when you first got in the leader
first two or three years before the
ankle like
you knew he was you knew he couldn't
shoot you know he didn't want to shoot
you gave him space and he still could
blow by you yeah he had the quickest
first step like that's what I'm saying
like I guarded Mike's Mike was older but
I guarded Kobe's first step like I felt
like I could get to Kobe you know what
I'm saying his [__] by you it just was
the quickest [__]
um the other person for me was Paul
Pierce
and Paul was because
obviously Hall of Fame a great player
but it was something about this game
that you felt like when he was guarding
them he was always off balance so you're
thinking like he's like falling but then
he just goes straight up right or you
think he's falling he just go keeps
going straight you know what I'm saying
so it was just and it was tricky it was
like janky you know what I'm saying so
that would be two and then three was uh
Zach Randolph yo Zebo was Beast bro and
Zebo was because
when you got done playing against Zebo
you felt like you just had a street
fight yeah he just was he physical he on
you all game like I used to feel like I
would be on offense and he's he's still
on me I'm like Zebo rotate bro you're on
defense like why are you still why your
body still online you know what I'm
saying so those would be the three in my
career that I felt like was just the
toughest what's crazy too we were
talking about the Pacers you actually
were with the Pacers two different times
so like the second because you came the
year after the malice what was it called
the mouse of the palace yeah you were
you were there the year after and I feel
like that was the year
where because Ron didn't play and I
think I do feel like at a certain point
in time Ron Artest might have been like
a top three guy in the league maybe for
like a half a season yeah and then all I
mean as Steven Jackson say I don't know
if you ever heard him say this but Steve
says he think he's the best two-way
basketball player ever
I mean look p
Eep we're on our tests
was very underrated I don't think people
remember it the right he was so [__]
good dog yeah he was so he was tough
like the [__] he did Miss games
like he had heart surgery played a day
after played the right way towards thumb
surgery they took the cast off in the
locker room played and this is all while
also kind of trying to have a rap career
for people who don't remember bro he was
yo
exactly right it wasn't even like he was
just locked in on basketball all the
time he was doing so much of the [__]
and he was that good but to your point
the year that I left they traded me for
Steven Jackson right
um that team I think if they didn't have
the malice in the palace they win the
championship day that's the year that
that's the year in my head that I think
like damn like that Team bro they were
gonna kneel bro they were gonna win 60
plus games for sure we had just won 60
games the year before you know what I'm
saying like they were about to and and
I'm even saying that with me leaving the
team I feel like I was on the team we
meet even better but like that that team
they had everything they had everything
they had every stacked they had
everything they were going to win it
that year but can you tell me um what's
it like to have Reggie Miller as a
teammate because he's supposed to be the
greatest smack talker ever him Gary
Payton Jordan you know whatever you want
to do but
people say he was kind of like a tough
guy you know like to play against in
terms of he would just talk about your
[__] kids like he didn't give a [__]
yeah I mean he talked [__] but Reggie
the ultimate competitor
um if you wasn't a Pacer you was like
for real like for real but I like he had
no other friends on other teams that's
amazing like he had that mindset
um first person in the gym last person
to leave for real not just you know you
hear it literally the first person in
the gym I sat as a rookie I used to
bring donuts and orange juice so you
know just say practice is at 11. if I
got there at nine he was already there
bro so I had to like try to beat him
because he was the one that wanted the
donuts right you understand what I'm
saying so I'm like having to be at the
gym at like 8 30 in the morning just to
kind of get there the same time as him
you know what I'm saying what I'm saying
um as far as on the court like you said
like I said like ultimate competitor he
didn't really he didn't really talk [__]
unless you said something or like
somebody on the bench said something
that's how all them guys were that's how
Mike was that's how Kobe was
um yeah if you give me some ammunition
they just want they just you know like
most times like I always say like when
we playing games and [__] like that
which is kind of dope like you know it
could be it's 20 30 000 people going
crazy but you don't hear it it's like a
silence that we play with you understand
what I'm saying but only thing we do
here is what's on the court and what's
on the benches you understand what I'm
saying so Reggie just waiting for
somebody to hear him take a shot and
like oh that's off you know what I'm
saying he like oh it's off oh just
anything to get them going you know what
I'm saying did you ever have like a
personal gripe because I've I'm real
close with a lot of NBA guys and like
some of their managers and stuff so
they'll give me like heads up like like
I'll know certain players will never
play with each other right if it's up to
them right whether it's over a girl or
whether it's over something you said
like for example like I've heard that
like
because of something Dennis Schroeder
said to Devin Booker he'll never play
for the Suns oh wow and and it's it's
kind of out there like Devin Booker went
and saw him in the locker room when he
was on the Rockets because he said some
[__] about his girl you know people kind
of know about it but like he'll never be
on the sons right
did you ever have something like that
with a guy and I'm sure you got over it
but like where you just were like man I
really don't [__] with that dude for
whatever reason maybe he said some [__]
on the court
no I I didn't personally nah and you
know and at the end of the day like you
know if the sons really want they uh
Schroeder like they had to just come to
a men's right you understand what I'm
saying like you could say that as much
as you want it feels so weird now
because so many NBA guys are dating the
same chicks these and I'm sure it was
always weird no it wasn't well maybe it
was we just it was no social media well
I was gonna say the social media makes
it where it's like everyone's following
the same chicks now right so the same
chicks getting flown out and there's a
lot of random like background beefs over
just girls that are for everybody right
which is weird it's super weird
[Laughter]
so weird yeah it's super weird I was
gonna say Obviously
um Viola is a very successful Endeavor
but you have always pivoted outside of
just getting your basketball check I
remember when you and uh Stephen Jackson
launched your shoe blind proteges and
the whole point of it was like to
provide like a very affordable Shoe
Right like for kids to work yeah man I
just you know
I think that like even when you make it
like you can't forget where you come
from right and you know I just thought
about like when I was a kid
um I love Michael Jordan right but I
couldn't afford to spend a hundred and
something dollars for Jordans right
right right and at the time Patrick
Ewing had sneakers right that was like
half the price and Anna uh Hakeem
Olajuwon had the shoes at Walmart the
Spaldings yeah
so like I thought about that and like
that I wore those and I felt empowered I
felt good I felt I felt dope showing
this showing up to school instead of
like with Jeepers or you know [__] that
had no name
and like especially where I come from
and I think where a lot of us come from
like you get empowered by what you wear
you know what I'm saying your appearance
it gives you more confidence and
different things like that so I was just
thinking about that and you know then
Stephon Marbury once again
you know what I'm saying he's always I
say I tell people a lot of times like a
lot of the swag I got I got from Steph
yeah you know what I'm saying from early
you know he like during that lockout I
was telling you about he let me come
stay with him for two months and he you
know I watched him lift weights and hoop
every day and he showed me a lot of like
you know what it takes to really survive
and if I want to be good you know so his
shoe that came out
um you know the deal fell through with
Stephen Barry they did some [__] and
undersold the shoe from and different
things like that and you know he decided
to go to China and everything so I was
like you know it's still a void here
yeah you know what I'm saying and you
know me stack and Fat Joe actually Fat
Joe is also a part of it yeah he had to
shoot too and uh you know those two my
brothers they support you know all the
Endeavors and you know I just wanted to
make some that you know kids could wear
because you know they just unfortunately
everybody can't afford LeBrons and
Jordan no you're right everything so if
other NBA players can come together for
sure to create a shoe you know what I'm
saying that they could feel good about
wearing you know it's more of them than
others you understand what I'm saying so
it was a huge success until you know
once again a bad partnership you know
one of the things I learned in business
is you got to know who you've been in
business with you know and so
um I feel like if I didn't have a bad
partnership I think it would probably
still be you know in in uh uh Kmart you
know yeah yeah I remember yeah yo you uh
you gotta have a pretty crazy collection
of like PE shoes in terms of just player
exclusives what is like your most
coveted pair of kicks where you're like
yo if I put these on stockx Force comes
to worst I you know I could pull a
little something so I'm gonna be honest
bro I I haven't I haven't seen my shoes
and probably about
storage they're in storage I have but I
haven't been to the storage in 10 years
wait you got a bunch of shoes and well
some of them I probably fell apart yeah
they probably that's why that's why I
haven't went did you get any like the
terror squads but they but they got some
new ones coming uh Fat Joe just called
me the other day he gonna send me the
new ones okay um
but yeah I had to I had the patent
leather ones with the red TS on them or
whatever then I think I had to pair with
the black TS on them as well but yeah I
had those
um what are some of like the the dopest
peas that like uh because did you have
like a because you know for people who
don't know like a lot of guys do have
shoe deals even if you don't like hear
about it like did you have like a yeah I
had a Nike contract but you know they
paid me not a lot of money right and you
know we would get like an allotment up
to like maybe 100 to 150 000 worth of
product every year every year so you
would get your peas peas made or
whatever so like for most of my career I
always had like a Nike that was part of
like the fourth division they called it
at that top and uh I would have like my
own colorway with my you know with my
logo on it or the logo that I made for
it or whatever yo uh when you were with
the Nuggets George Carl was the coach
George Carl is a wild guy on Twitter God
bless him his Twitter's lit yeah I'm
saying he don't he George Carlin doesn't
give a [__] for people who have not been
paying attention what was I playing for
George Carl
because took the sonics to the finest I
[__] with George because he told
because he's exactly who he is he's not
phony you know you you know you know who
you're getting you know exactly what
you're dealing with right so my first my
first running with him was um
he had called me and he had called me
into his office and um he wanted to talk
to me and he was asking me like
uh he's actually like maybe why didn't I
rebound I had a higher clip and he had
all these books behind him
and like the one book that stood out to
me right it was like it was like it was
called [__] right and um you know he
had it up there whatever so that it
brought me the wrong way just reading
that right so then it kind of made my
whole conversation with him kind of like
I felt a little funny but whatever so it
was just in there whatever and um
he's like tell asking me all these
different things and then we you know so
then we start kind of going at it a
little bit and then what he said to me
he was just like well you know I've won
50 games a year for the last five years
how many games have you won that was
coming from the Knicks right right so
I'm like [__] we ain't win but I'm just
like
how many games did you play right you
know what I'm saying like so I'm saying
all that to say was he was the type of
Coach where when we won games it was
because of him
when we lost games it was because the
players it was because of the players he
didn't take any accountability you know
none right you know what I'm saying like
that was the type of Coach he was and I
said and even through all of that bro
like he's actually a friend of mine like
I actually still like him did you guys
ever talk about the book never got a
chance to talk about the book
um I thought it was very interesting
that he had it in there like that and I
don't know what it was about but it was
you know I never yeah as soon as I'm
leaving his office I'm like what is this
book yeah I know I should let me see the
context then we might really have an
interesting conversation I was already
mad at her I even think about like
looking to see what the what the book
said but uh but for the most part like I
like George you know I mean he had his
run-ins with all of us at some point but
you know I think that his intentions was
always to win you know I'm saying which
is West what we're all there for you
know what I'm saying and you know um I
would say he was a teacher at the game
yeah you know what I'm saying he taught
you I mean I mean you played really good
in Denver too yeah this one's and like
the so the first year was that year in
the next year when Melo left is that's
when me and him actually became really
cool right you know what I'm saying was
that next year was when we started to
jail or whatever and you know like I
said you know if George calls me and say
let's go to lunch and then I'll go okay
so we got Alan Iverson in the weed game
finally finally you got the Iverson here
yes sir
um I I kind of saw you a little bit of
you guys talking about you kind of you
know reaching out to him to do this
[Music]
um
talk about like for you
because you know I can't think of
another player who I'd like to see have
a strain then AI you know what I'm
saying for you though like uh were you
an out always close throughout your
playing years or was it something where
like you know you guys got closer after
so I would definitely say we got closer
after but um whenever we saw each other
was always loved and you know I was
obviously seeing each other off the
court a lot of times it was in like
clubs and you know [__] like that so you
know you kick it yeah you know have some
drinks talk about whatever was going on
um and you know kind of go from there
but I think that the one thing that I
will say is like with Chuck was that
when he came in he really revolutionized
the game 100 point right and because you
came in he was what two years in when
you got drafted right he came in with 96
96 yeah 98 yeah yeah so two years in and
at that point bro he was just changing
the game the jewelry the tattoos the
braids the clothes made people buy
when we were playing when we would play
against them we all would be sitting on
the bus waiting to go down the ramp to
see what car Allen Iverson drove that
yeah you know what I'm saying like he
was like he was you know he was like
showing us like how you really want to
live like you know like when I came in
I'll say like the the Vets was you know
they were all vets so they would you
know they were wearing suits
his mother was on the team so like you
know they driving they got like one car
yeah you know what I'm saying it was
just the conservative guy and they
weren't making as much money either you
know what I'm saying certain kind of
made sense but so that was the kind of
the way that they saw the world so when
they talking to me as a young guy that's
how they see in the world that's how
they telling me and then Alan Iverson
and it's like well [__] I'd rather ball
like that did a lot of the veterans like
in the league not like him because of
that energy he was bringing I don't
think so I mean I never heard nobody say
that they didn't like him because you
know it's I feel like like you said like
back then it was a different League it
was very like you know [__] a lot of the
great players played a very long time
yeah and they were I think though I
think the the Vets they more would talk
[__] around the contracts not your
personal life for like what you did or
how you drove how you dressed right
it'll be more like this motherfucker's
got 100 million dollars it's almost got
80 million dollars and you know and
you're comparing the stats and it's
almost like how I could be I could be a
you know and I'm not gonna say they were
bitter but you know I I get it because
they were literally making one two
million dollars and then now guys making
12. and 15. you know what I'm saying and
you know I could easily be like oh this
guy making 30 million dollars I've
averaged more than that that was kind of
that was more like the way that they
would be talking you know what I'm
saying
um but I think for the most part
everybody I think you had to support AIX
I think that
the way he was doing it is the way you
really wanted to be yeah for sure he was
like the first person that was really
himself like apologize yeah that's
what's telling me to fit into a box
right now you got to do this you got to
do that you got to look this way you got
to walk this way you got to eat this you
gotta and Alan came in and was like [__]
all that I feel like it was like him and
Steph that's why I like Steph too
because Steph always had he had that
chain with the S on it yeah he had one
booming you know and I used to he went
in competition with each other they were
them too they definitely were because I
really love each other but they was
incoming I love both of them but I would
have my Reeboks and my the and ones were
more affordable shout out to add one
yeah emoji and one shorts and t-shirts
with the like guy holding the rim and
[__] on the back man [__] and one was
lit man I think anyone's still the thing
I think no it's coming back well it's
that Walmart I think are they but
they're definitely coming back I'm
seeing more ads there on like this thing
called Clash TV in New York right I'm
saying they pushing hey let's stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good Folks at King Palm that's right
man shout out to King Palm uh we're
talking about nothing but that organic
all right that Nash Corral Them Leafs
all right there's no tobacco involved
and they're so smooth when you smoke in
them I love King Palms the only thing
I'm smoking out of now if you go to your
local uh liquor store you go to your
local smoke shop you can get King Palms
of course 7-Eleven's got the king pongs
and they have so many crazy flavors like
shout out to Sugar Shawn who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discreetly of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you can tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right blueshoe.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview what was um again Hooper you
love this [__] you did Big Three
um and uh you know I think big three is
super dope I enjoy it I think I wish
they'd be able to embrace it more
because I do think it's like a really
cool
off-season thing right you know like for
you what was that what was it like being
would you start season two of it I did
the first two seasons what was it like
though just just because you know there
were some old heads out there there were
some younger dudes who couldn't get in
the league like like how serious was the
competition level in the big three so it
was it was it was pretty serious because
remember we all competitors right right
and then in this environment Amari was
playing I think yeah but but in this
environment you couldn't get you
couldn't hide right so like I'll say
this about my career right I feel like I
could have been a lot better right if I
got a different opportunities right
especially when I was younger right like
maybe if you could end up on the Spurs
or something yeah or or if I was maybe
the second go-to guy on the team instead
of the third or fourth you understand
what I'm saying like so now when you get
to this three on three thing it's like
you canned up so it's like and I'm using
the Mario as an example even though like
we have no beef or nothing but it's like
okay when I played against Amari and his
sons he was getting touches I had to
just mow a guard and I just had to get
my open threes right but in this Omari
got to guard me now one-on-one so now
it's different yeah and I'm gonna bust
your ass and he wasn't the greatest
defensive guy no no no do we just use
him as an example like he did great and
I'm just using him his examples I love
him but I'm just saying like I could go
at him in this environment compared to
during the season I had to fit the mole
and play the role because Baron and
Knight away from Monte and I had to wait
for stack Jack before I could get mines
right you understand what I'm saying so
that was the biggest thing that I think
even Allen experienced immediately
because it was like he had been busting
everybody's ass his whole career now
they he can't hide he got to do he got a
guard So Adam only played two weeks yeah
that's what Allen did not he stopped
playing because he was like I can keep
letting these dudes go at me I can't I
ain't I'm not okay everybody was going
to him because honestly like I remember
that was the big grab when they
announced big three like oh hey he was
the no he he was the face of it yeah it
was only him for sure he's the reason
why big three is Big Three now you get
like ISO Joe yeah but it was it was ai
ai made the big three you know he was
the number one person he was the lead
person blah blah blah blah but at the
end of the day in that environment
we CA I killed so like we won the first
year we didn't lose the game we went we
went undefeated and wanted the first
Champions the first year championship
and then the second year uh we didn't
play as well we had like Rashawn mccance
came back as a character yeah but the
first year all I was telling everybody
to hold him like he's like I turned to
make a roster guy yeah NBA yeah like
Cole in that way we were Shaq and Kobe
in the big three that's why I kept
calling us Shaq and Kobe because kid
nobody got us we talked about uh some of
the what was your favorite coach you
played for was it because he played for
Larry Bird right yeah Larry
so like Larry Larry got mad at me from
the day I met him I missed my flight for
my press conference oh so he was he's
already was like yeah he just he like
being like being late is the worst thing
you could do with him is being late he
does not play that [__] so literally the
first time I met him walking to the
office and he was like I don't play that
late [__] before he said hi happy to
have you on the team he's like I don't
play that late [__] that's some [__]
and I felt like he always held that
against me the two years I was there but
Larry was not a coach per se he was a
gay manager uh we had a guy because you
had you had like red like Chris Mullen
and all this but you still gotta run
plays right right he never did that like
he he never wrote in two years never
wrote an x-ro oh really never once he
had uh Rick Carlisle offensive coach
great coach by the way yep and then we
had uh the coach uh Brendan Malone so he
just had like coordinators yeah exactly
and he was and he just subbed he just
turned around like oh you get this
person hey time
he's calling timeout to seven that's
what he would do but my favorite coach
was um so I would say my best xno coach
was Rick Carlisle shout out to Ray
Carlos like bro whatever he draws up
works every time you're gonna get an
open shot for sure every time
um he's back in Indiana right back in
Indiana but my my favorite coach that I
enjoyed playing for was where I had the
where we had the least amount of success
was Mike Woodson Michael that was for
them oh that was in it oh that's right
you were with the Hawks for him because
like I got traded for Steven Jackson
when the malice in the Palestine so that
was my that that was my favorite coach
and the reason why I liked him so much
was once again man I'm just a huge I I
you know I'm huge on like integrity and
just like
just being straight up with people and
like I just felt like the two years I
was with him he never lied to me once
bro he told me whether I liked it or not
you know what I'm saying he told me what
was the truth and uh you know for that
Joe Johnson was on that team Joe came
the next year my first year no joke
first year was like second year he had
Joe second year we had Joe first year
was like me Antoine Walker Kevin Willis
rookies we had like Josh Smith Josh
Childress oh shout out to Josh Childress
man one of the greatest Pros in NBA
history Uh Kevin Willis had to be like
50. wait no he plays so much he played
so long it's crazy yo did Joe Johnson
ever like confide in you how he felt
about how the sons did because I felt
like if we would have kept Joe Johnson I
feel like
we might have had a championship bro we
let Joe Johnson just walk because yeah
he came I mean I mean and then he goes
to the Hawks and then they become a
perennial playoff team yeah he was one
of the most underrated players you know
what I'm saying of his time for sure but
hey man I saw Joe was a monster did you
guys uh ever trade back and forth about
uh like later on how much you guys
didn't like Mike dantoni
nah you know he I don't I want to see me
and him never had a conversation about
Mike but I might hit him up and ask him
though okay so what was yeah it was like
yeah did you really hate this guy uh
well look man um obviously the the so
can you kind of break down because I
don't think a lot of people understand a
lot of the business model when it comes
to
the weed game I think a lot of people
think it's like like we're talking off
off the air it's like
you get in the weed game and you just
print money which is not the case so
many companies they they they're they're
here for six months they're here for two
years and then they're gone like you
said you you're 12 years in for you guys
are you guys
strictly distro wholesale
um you guys don't have a dispensary
license do you yeah so my my company got
a bunch of layers to it okay what I'm
saying um a lot of markets yeah we had a
bunch of markets we're in I think we're
in like 10 markets total
um in a variation of different like ways
right so uh for the viola brand you know
we have uh cultivated or operated in
California Oregon Michigan and Colorado
um to your point now the entry has
changed so much
um I think the asset light uh approach
which means to what you said focusing on
wholesaling focusing more on just The
Branding
um you know the sell through and
different things like that is probably
the way to go if you're trying to scale
a brand almost like the kind of cookies
model yeah
um but even that's difficult because
then you got to have a hell of a
procurement team and make sure like the
quality control is Right quality control
is the main thing right it's everything
right but you know so either way it's
very difficult both ways right
um we also have started opening up some
retail locations through a like sister
company that we have called Village
um you know so Viola owns a percentage
of village and all of the Village
locations are named Viola so we have so
you guys do have sore fronts so yeah so
we have two uh we have two in Missouri
okay we have two in Illinois about to
open up we have one in Jersey we're
about to open we're about to open one up
in Maryland uh you know we hope to get
something going down in Florida
um and then also New York we're working
on New York currently is it crazy for
you to go to New York as a kid from the
east coast and see how open the week
like have you been in New York City
recently of course it is like
the craziest [__] I've ever seen it's
like like people think like it's Federal
legalization people think like
California is like everyone's out here
smoke weed now you go to New York and
you're just walking in the park and
there's a bunch of dudes with fold up
tables selling drugs it's crazy near
cops or you go to the store to buy a
juice and a sandwich and the guy behind
the back he's got all kind of weed and
shrooms and [__] it's [__] quiet yeah
New York and it happens New York is
definitely the Wild Wild West they
decriminalized and everybody just is
NYPD just don't care they're just like
hey dude at the end of the day which is
good it's prohibition right great yeah
sometimes you gotta you gotta take
advantage it's just wild to see they're
like contrast yeah it's crazy you know
to your point like I remember there was
a point you like you said you you know
you rode through the city I mean one
time I had got some weed in New York and
I was still playing but it's the
summertime and I got pulled over and I
just picked up a couple ounces from
somebody and it would have my whole car
stinking and I was so scared yeah and
the cop took my stuff and everything and
you know I told him it's a new truck
that's why the plate was wrong whatever
and he literally my license and
insurance back and was like stop smoking
in the car I hadn't even smoked I was
just you know what I'm saying but he
could have literally locked me up for it
yeah you know what I'm saying to like to
your point now I could be blazing he
pulled me over like what's up you want
to hit this
you know what I'm saying so it's
definitely changed a lot and you know I
think that the New York program on the
legal side is probably going to be one
of the best in the industry I think
because of the way that they are trying
to make sure that
um Legacy
um people that were disproportionately
affected by the war on drugs are like
winners and that are participating in
the beginning and not in the you know
later like most States because most
States they give all these big companies
these opportunities and they say okay
now we're going to let you know the
people that you know the poor people get
in and I always say like I used a
comparison is like playing against the
Warriors and spotting them 20 30 points
and then saying go out and play
literally what happened yeah you know
what I'm saying so with New York they're
doing it you know totally they're doing
it the right way they're rolling it out
properly and um I'm excited for the New
York Market I think it's going to be
probably the biggest in the country
um what were did you ever have to dodge
piss tests
no in the NBA no I didn't I didn't smoke
until like I told you that one time and
then my last year in the league
um I was just using more CBD and stuff
like that I always wanted to keep my my
record clean just in case because you
know they say they don't keep tabs on
all that stuff but they do you know what
I'm saying and then you get like a
stigma on you that's like kind of unfair
because then they talk about it on a
sports center it's like who cares it's
weeds like you know and especially now
is now okay and then you know they
allowed it in the bubble out of nowhere
right you had one of your facilities be
legally rated in Detroit right correct
so what can you give me a breakdown what
happened there yeah so pretty much
um you know and how long ago was this
this was I think six years ago now but
what happens is like in all these states
you know you go through this whole
process right and at the end of the day
unfortunately it's still like regular
state workers that are responsible for a
lot of the information and all that kind
of stuff and like even when I apply for
licenses like bro I'm literally giving
everybody every bank account every lease
every this every day like all these
different states these people have all
my information bro yeah yeah
so you go through that whole process and
you know you get these permits you get
all these different things to operate
and you know certain things happen so
what happened for us was you know
someone jumps off the bridge our
facility is right next to the uh
Ambassador Bridge that goes from Detroit
into Windsor Canada uh they're looking
for the body allegedly the Coast Guard
comes past our building they smell weed
they call the city or the police the
police call the city the lady at the
city who's in charge is on vacation so
they talk to like her assistant who
doesn't know the [__] going on don't
doesn't know looks at the paperwork oh I
had I don't have that address anywhere
on any files
the gang unit exercises a a warrant on
the building the gang unit the gang unit
they come in they dress regular so I'm
at home my aunt calls me and she says I
think we're getting robbed I look on the
camera and everybody got on regular
clothes bro so I'm like oh [__] y'all so
I'm like you know you know the procedure
go Lock It Go lock yourself in the back
right
um I'm looking on the camera she's still
looking on the camera because the
camera's in that back room then we see a
Paddy Wagon that comes by that says
Detroit police so I'm like oh Auntie is
the police cool you got all the
paperwork just go open the door at this
point they're Ram in the door she opens
the door before they have to bust it
down and she's trying to give them the
paperwork and all I see on the camera is
just an AR go to her face in the
paperwork form or whatever so they back
her into the door and they all running
through the door they ramming the other
door down and the other engine still
ramming RAM and ramming and then like
literally three minutes later the
cameras is cut
so now I can't see anything oh so now
I'm nervous as hell you know thinking
like what happened like you know I'm
still me right I don't want to go to
jail right you know you understand what
I'm saying and long story short man it
was just some Mix-Ups at the city level
um and you know they had to let
everybody out did they uh pay for any of
that did they damage your [__] they
damaged all of our [__] they took all of
our equipment what they did was they put
us on the news that night with our
address
4473 West Jefferson Avenue and they left
the warehouse open
so allegedly someone comes in there with
equipment that know how to take down
lights and know how to take HVAC off the
roof and they just completely wiped us
out over two days because it took me two
days to get there
you know what I'm saying by the time I
got there my warehouse was empty
well you know they say this about
Detroit they will got a [__] a house
out there they'll take the copper out
that [__] they'll take Detroit
is known for that [__] like if you got a
house in Detroit and it's not occupied
good luck bro you need but just get all
my [__] like you needed ladders you
needed like oh it was probably the
police it was probably like one of the
cops cousins okay bro they got us bro so
it's probably so whoever out there got
our equipment and we started your
growing all that y'all can send us a
little thank you or something man
because you know they got state of the
art equipment bro it was like all the
equipment were you able to sue we're in
the Pro we're in a lawsuit still at all
this time Jesus and still you know they
have like this immunity because they're
police it's just it's all bad bro yeah
um how much uh frustration do you have
dealing with weird
listen man the marijuana industry is
full of a lot of weirdos yes sir very
much guy's not of the culture guys
who've never were involved in weed in
their life corporate dudes I mean I've
dealt with it a lot where I'm just like
these are the [__] weenies that are
making decisions that some of these
companies and then that's when you see
like certain like Brands like fall like
fall off or even like dispensary brands
that are like really big Brands but it's
like a bunch of weirdo like you know uh
VC guys running them like like for you
being a guy who you know obviously cares
about a plant cares so much about this
like the benefits of weed and just the
culture and all that [__] like is it
well frustrating dealing with some of
the weird [__] that you have to deal
because I talked to burner about the
[__] all the time burner deals with a
lot of weirdos yeah yeah it's very
frustrating but it's just part of the
business bro like you know we're still
pioneering the industry and your point
is a lot of people that's going to come
and go you know what I'm saying but you
gotta it's all gonna weed itself out and
you just got to be a part of the process
you know what I'm saying so yeah I'd be
frustrated but not that frustrated you
know I'm saying I've kind of gotten used
to it you know I think that once again
also because of my background being of
course yeah yeah
so I'm a pro exactly so for me I guess
it doesn't bother me as much but to your
point yes
um there's a lot of weird [__] going on
in the industry a lot of weird people in
it
um and like I said bro we'll see how
long it takes to wean it all out but
it's gonna be a while
um how many shelves you guys on
um we're in California yeah you're in
county or in Cali so we've we've been to
approach like small batch product or
whatever so we're in probably about 25
stores okay yeah what's the biggest
market for viola uh right now it's
Michigan Michigan's booming yeah
Michigan and then I would say second is
Florida oh yeah we did a partnership
with a company called flowery that's
booming dope and then I so what I like
about what you're doing is like
introducing new strains new Partnerships
um
have you because because I I know you uh
had did berners Roundtable no I haven't
done or you guys you guys did an
interview or something uh no I haven't
done it set it's on YouTube I watched it
me and Berner yeah
did I maybe I definitely I smoked that
much it's just like it was probably like
five years ago four or five years ago I
did an interview with Bernie notch
I don't know if it was an interview it
was you guys chopping it up I've done
I've done some like Zoom stuff with him
maybe I'm am I tripping hold on let me
see
because I swear to God I thought I saw
this I thought you were sitting oh I
know what he's talking about I did at uh
right here at burner interviews Al
Harrington let me see
oh yeah that was way back in the day
you're right we did that right here on
Sunset you're right I gotta know I'm not
crazy
I forgot I forgot I was gonna say like
um have you got any advice from a guy
like burn in terms of like he's done
such a good job of like building out
like the franchise model on the on the
um
you know on the dispensary side and then
obviously introducing your strains
constantly that's why I thought it was
Dopey to the Iverson [__] because I was
like oh that makes sense you know yeah
nah yeah um yeah we talk all the time
every time we see each other like the
last time I saw him um well I saw him
when he did the Erica Badu thing here in
Cali but before that where we actually
got a chance to sit in the trailer and
talk for about an hour was down in
Atlanta for the Revolt conference but
yeah so he's always just you know giving
me his perspective what's going on and
you know the one thing that I would say
like is consistent every time we talk is
all about the quality of the week always
you know what I'm saying like you find
good weed make a cool bag of the cell
yeah you know what I'm saying and like
kind of keep it simple stupid kind of
vibe 100 so
um you know big shout out to burn the
big guy shot big shout out to what he's
done he's definitely you know
well listen whatever wherever you're at
well not wherever you're at but if
this [__] is I smell the irishness guess
shout out to Viola
um I appreciate you pulling up man and
talking and uh thanks for having me
congrats on the 12 12 years yeah 12
years in this [__] yeah man hey so go
support and then for people who don't
know like uh what's the Instagram where
can people kind of find out more check
out uh yeah our Instagram is at Viola
um you know we have so I have some other
tags outside of that but go to that
Viola first he'll get you there uh
violabrands.com is the website and if
you want to get some of this cool ass
fire yeah I got the real merch yeah go
to violagoods.com we got a bunch of new
[__] dropping over the next couple weeks
we got sneakers we did a collab with
cool car
um we're doing a collab with uh Lambo
King on some merch on some T-shirts and
hoodies you know what I'm saying so go
check it out bro boom my guy Al
Harrington appreciate you pulling up
right now yes sir thank you we have to
make it happen yes sir boom hey this
interview is brought to you by our good
Folks at hardean all right shout out to
the Jardine family in Las Vegas make
sure you follow them Harding underscore
Las Vegas and number one dispensary
period all right the craziest selection
of Premium premium cannabis you can ask
for plus when you go to
hardinlasvegas.com you can check out all
the other cool stuff they got going on
you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to hardine and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're going to
take care of you Harding underscore Las
Vegas go follow them and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon